[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a este noticiero
especial de France 24 en español
especial por qué porque les traemos
algunas de las principales noticias que
acapararán la atención del mundo en el
próximo año 2023 y también Vamos a
abordar otras que son la continuidad de
hechos y eventos que marcaron este 2022
Comencemos en Ucrania porque la invasión
rusa cumplirá un año el próximo 24 de
febrero Y todavía hay incertidumbre
sobre cómo continuará Nadie puede decir
cuándo terminará la guerra ni tampoco
como pero algunos meses de lucha han
dejado varios lineamientos y también
interrogantes y uno de estos tiene que
ver con el proceso de reconstrucción de
un país destruido infraestructuras
claves fueron arrasadas afectando no
solo las residencias de los ucranianos
también los servicios esenciales de agua
calefacción y electricidad que estima
que la causa requerirá de al menos
350.000 millones de dólares para
analizar el escenario de reconstrucción
y sus implicancias tanto para Ucrania
como para la comunidad internacional nos
acompaña Jesús agreda a rudenco él es
analista internacional señor agreda
rudenco Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en Franz 24
Muchas gracias por la invitación Bueno
la como decíamos no la reconstrucción
implica cifras millonarias no cómo se
podrá financiar esto las arcas públicas
serán suficientes o deberá aparecer el
sector privado
es una combinación de los dos factores
de hecho desde el mismo septiembre y
principios de octubre el sector privado
por ejemplo en Alemania había mostrado
interés en participar en el proceso de
reconstrucción pero está claro que el
principal financiador deberá ser el
sector público y creo que es otra de las
razones por las cuales el presidente
viajó a Estados Unidos porque por un
lado se habló muchísimo de la necesidad
de financiar digamos el enfoque bélico o
el esfuerzo bélico de Ucrania y seguir
manteniendo ese apoyo militar de Estados
Unidos Pero por otro lado no podemos
olvidar que el presidente también tuvo
que aire acondicionado necesariamente
del tema de una posible reconstrucción y
no son el corto sino también el
inmediato plazo para Ucrania dado que el
invierno requiere la recuperación de la
infraestructura energética que ya se
mencionó Y eso cuesta mucho dinero y
usted gane no la tiene y Ucrania tiene
que buscar financiadores para
esas iniciativas Europa parece que
tendrá un rol clave en este proceso de
reconstrucción Cómo afectará la economía
del continente Y hasta qué punto podrá
seguir ayudando a Europa Es una muy
buena pregunta y la verdad es que
depende mucho de la forma como se supere
el invierno porque dependiendo de las
condiciones del Invierno vamos a ver qué
tanto apoyo popular podría seguir
teniendo el esfuerzo bélico ucraniano el
presidente ha insistido una y otra vez
en que es una guerra no solo por salvar
a Ucrania sino una guerra por de alguna
forma salvar el mundo y salvar Europa lo
cual digamos justifica la necesidad de
mantener este compromiso de la población
europea sobre todo en Estados Unidos que
financian en últimas esta guerra con sus
impuestos sin embargo de nuevo
dependiendo de cómo
estas mismas personas pueden superar
este invierno que se viene y sobre todo
dependiendo de cómo la la economía siga
siga funcionando principios del próximo
año veremos Cómo se puede mantener o no
ese apoyo el riesgo por supuesto para
Ucrania es que si la economía europea no
se reactiva y finalmente Los costos
siguen siendo muy altos en los niveles
de desempleo siguen aumentando la
inflación sigue disparada por supuesto
ese apoyo será reduciendo eventualmente
pueden haber algunos impactos en las
elecciones y el apoyo de Ucrania se
puede perder claro mencionaba usted a
Estados Unidos no Qué papel juega en
todo este proceso se limita a un rol
quizás más vinculado a la ayuda
armamentística que de reconstrucción son
las dos necesariamente son las dos
Estados Unidos es solo no solo líder en
apoyo militar sino también es el
principal financiador de alguna forma de
la guerra en Ucrania o del apoyo a
Ucrania en esta guerra y eso no es solo
al aspecto militar creo que Estados
Unidos tiene un papel que jugar para
motivar y digamos liderar todo ese
esfuerzo de reconstrucción económica
Jesús hereda Rubén con Muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en Franz 24 en
español un gusto bueno avanzamos con más
información porque ante la amenaza que
representa un vecino como Rusia Suecia y
Finlandia abandonaron su histórica
neutralidad militar y anunciaron
entonces su intención de incorporarse a
la organización del tratado del
Atlántico Norte hablamos por supuesto de
la otan una adhesión que podría
concretarse en 2023 y que ha tenido como
principales objetores que retrasaron el
proceso de ratificación a Hungría y a
Turquía el Primer Ministro húngaro
Víctor Urban adelantó que el parlamento
de su país tratará la ratificación de la
ampliación de la otan en su primera
sesión de 2023 Mientras que el
presidente Turco recetas dijo que la
adherencia no Debería ser ratificada
antes del año próximo cuando el país
celebre elecciones generales
en 2022 revivieron las tensiones entre
China y Taiwán por lo que No tardaron en
llegar las hipótesis sobre un eventual
conflicto armado el disparador fue la
visita a la isla de la expresidenta de
la cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos Nancy pelosi considerada como una
provocación por parte de Beijing que
recordemos que reclama su soberanía
sobre la isla por considerarla una
provincia Rebelde desde que los
nacionalistas del coming tan se
replegaron así en 1949 tras perder la
guerra civil contra los comunistas el
viaje de velocígeno enfrentamientos
retóricos y también movilizaciones
militares poniendo en peligro una frágil
Paz
la paz entre China y Taiwán se alteró en
2022 Y el interrogante sobre un eventual
invasión de Beijing a taipei volvió a
instalarse podría ocurrir en 2023
las tensiones se reavivaron en agosto
cuando Nancy pelosi por entonces
presidenta la cámara de representantes
de Estados Unidos viajó a Taiwán para
Beijing la visita cruzó una línea roja
al considerar cualquier presencia de un
alto funcionario extranjero en esa zona
como una forma de respaldar su
proclamada independencia
china tomará medidas firmes y enérgicas
para salvaguardar su soberanía nacional
e integridad territorial un pequeño
número de políticos estadounidenses y
fuerzas separatistas intentan desafiar
el principio de una sola china no son
conscientes de sus límites y están
condenados al fracaso
pero así se fue y dejó un escenario
cargado detenciones china disparó
misiles balísticos sobre la isla envío
decenas de barcos y aviones militares
Taiwán respondió desplazando aviones de
combates y navíos esta Isla es uno de
los puntos conflictivos en los vínculos
entre China y Estados Unidos Washington
es el principal proveedor de armas a
Taiwán y podría ser su Aliado militar en
caso de una guerra hoy la isla dirigida
por la presidenta saint-en y su partido
progresista democrático la líder se
manifestó dispuesta a dialogar mientras
las autoridades taiwanesas no descartan
las intenciones chinas de invadir su
territorio
china ha utilizado los ejercicios y su
hoja de ruta militar para prepararse
para la invasión de Taiwán Está
realizando ejercicios militares a gran
escala y lanzamientos de misiles así
como ataques cibernéticos una campaña de
desinformación y coerción económica para
debilitar la moral pública en Taiwán
el tema era que se desencadene una
guerra si china inventa y Taiwán ha
estado en el tablero geopolítico durante
décadas la creciente afirmación de China
como potencia global y los esfuerzos de
Estados Unidos por contenerla aumentaron
las tensiones en 2022 y dejan varias
inquietudes hacia 2023
y América Latina volverá a vivir
elecciones en distintos países de la
región en 2023 Sin embargo a diferencia
de 2022 donde el continente tuvo un
direccionamiento hacia la izquierda en
2023 son los candidatos de derecha lo
que están bien posicionados para ganar
en Argentina Paraguay y en Guatemala
veamos el informe el estado civil el
viraje hacia la izquierda que América
Latina tuvo en 2022 con las victorias en
Colombia y Brasil Podría tener su
contracara en 2023 año en el que la
derecha está bien perfilada para las
elecciones en Argentina y Paraguay en
Argentina la disputa se centra más en
quién sucederá Alberto Fernández con la
internada del macrismo y la emergente
figura del ultraderechista Javier milei
en la Vereda contraria un peronismo que
no tendrá a su máxima referente Cristina
Fernández de kirchner
en ninguna boleta termino el 10 de
diciembre y me vuelvo como me volví el
10 de diciembre del 2015 a mi casa en
Paraguay el ciclo de Mario abdo Benítez
tiene fecha de expiración luego del
triunfo en las internas del candidato de
honor Colorado una decisión oficialista
integrada entre otros por bloques de
derecha el aspirante presidencial de
honor Colorado será Santiago Peña ex
ministro de hacienda de Horacio cartes
su pasado como funcionario de fondo
monetario internacional lo elevaría como
la opción preferida para el
establishment paraguayo mientras en
Guatemala continúan las tensiones en
torno al tribunal superior electoral que
tendrá comicios en enero y es acusado de
ser manejado por el gobierno conservador
de Alejandro yamatei con este panorama
el 2023 puede romper la tendencia
progresista hacia la que se inclinó
parte de la región en 2022 dejando una
latinoamérica ideológicamente aún más
fragmentada
seguimos en América Latina porque en
2023 Brasil inaugura una nueva era
política bajo el mandato de Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva el líder progresista
regresa al poder tras cuatro años de
gobierno del ultraderechista Jair
bolsonaro y lo esperan varios desafíos
Como por ejemplo el de unir a un país
polarizado con un movimiento
proporcionado que parece haber llegado
para quedarse pero la grieta social no
es el único reto para Lula da Silva que
recibe un país con considerables
desafíos en materia económica el hambre
afecta a unas 33 millones de personas
según la red brasileña de investigación
en soberanía y seguridad alimentaria
mientras que a nivel medioambiental es
clave la protección de la selva
amazónica que recordemos alcanzó niveles
récord de deforestación bajo la
presidencia de Jair bolsonaro
vamos ahora con otras noticias que
acaparará la atención en 2023 el espacio
será escenario de varios eventos y
además podremos vernos hacer algunas
ansiadas tecnologías en abril de 2023 la
agencia espacial europea lanzará la
misión su objetivo será explorar Júpiter
su entorno y 3 de sunas Europa calisto y
ganimedes al analizar este sistema
Planetario la esa espera aprender más
sobre los mundos helados que rodean al
gigante gaseoso y la posibilidad de
hallar vida
los avances en los vuelos espaciales
privados continuarán en 2023 space x
espera enviar a susakumaisawa un
multimillonario japonés a volar
alrededor de la luna junto a ocho
personas que se postularon en línea para
participar las misiones lunares son los
primeros pasos de spacex en el mercado
del turismo espacial y los taxis aéreos
eléctricos esperan despegar en 2023 en
un año crucial para los desarrolladores
de aeronaves eléctricas de despegue y
aterrizaje vertical conocidos
popularmente Como taxis voladores varias
compañías aguardan la certificaciones
para comenzar con la producción
comercial y los primeros servicios de
pasajeros
y la lucha contra el cambio climático
continuará en el año 2023 en un
escenario de polémicas y suspicacias Y
es que la cop28 se llevará a cabo en
emiratos árabes Unidos una nación
relevante en la producción de energías
fósiles y los expertos medioambientales
ya avisoran intentos de los petroestados
para dictar acuerdos que les sean
favorables sobre la reducción de
emisiones de carbono veamos el informe
la lucha contra el cambio climático dejó
avances aunque también deudas pendientes
en la copa 27 de Egipto y el 2023 se
presenta controversial al ser la cumbre
en emiratos árabes Unidos una potencia
en la producción de combustibles fósiles
tras una cop donde el acuerdo más
relevante refiere a la aprobación de un
fondo de compensaciones y pérdidas
Naciones Unidas insiste en que los
progresos son escasos mientras el tiempo
corre
todavía nos estamos moviendo claramente
en la dirección equivocada La Brecha de
misiones globales está creciendo el
objetivo de 1,5 grados se está quedando
sin aliento los planes climáticos
nacionales se están quedando
Lamentablemente cortos
en la cop 28 la gran disputa estará
centrada en los combustibles fósiles los
analistas y activistas medioambientales
temen que los acuerdos se direccionen en
favor de las empresas petroleras de gas
y de carbón en un país que centra su
economía en la explotación de estas
energías
en 2023 año donde la intención es
avanzar sobre la reducción de emisiones
de carbono el temor ronda que los
estados petroleros aprovechen el marco
de la cumbre en Dubai para dictar los
términos de la transición en su
beneficio y finalizamos con algunos de
los eventos deportivos que veremos en
2023 del 20 de Julio al 19 de agosto se
disputará la Copa Mundial femenina de la
FIFA 2023 la selección de Estados Unidos
actual campeona defenderá el título en
la primera edición organizada
conjuntamente en dos países Australia y
Nueva Zelanda también será la primera en
contar con 32 seleccionados frente a los
24 de 2019
Santiago la capital de Chile será
escenario de los Juegos Panamericanos y
para Panamericanos 2023 más de 8.000
atletas en 39 deportes Panamericanos y
17 para Panamericanos harán parte del
evento multideportivo más grande que ha
realizado este país sudamericano toda su
historia y 2023 será un año clave para
los fanáticos del básquetbol la décimo
novena edición de la Copa del Mundo de
la fiba se llevará a cabo por primera
vez en tres países anfitriones filipinas
Japón e Indonesia del 25 de agosto al 10
de septiembre 32 selecciones asegurarán
sus lugares en la etapa clasificatoria
que finalizará en febrero
Muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos
finalizamos Este programa especial sobre
las noticias del año 2023 sigan en
France 24 y también por supuesto en
frank24.com
[Música]